we're doing the draft of the guys under
the most pressure
you get the trivia question are you
ready what is it andy reid is set to
coach his 27th postseason game on sunday
in the history of the nfl only three
coaches have appeared in more postseason
games name two of them
only three coaches have appeared in more
postseason 27. okay so bill belichick's
one of them you are correct okay and
then after that i mean
[Music]
gosh i want to just say
i want to say bill walsh
you are incorrect
it was a good guess and he was because
he retired earlier don shula and tom
landry oh yeah that's stupid i should
have got that you're right all right all
right all this talk about kirk cousins
for me the first pick in the draft is
not kirk cousins it's the other
quarterback whoa the other quarter
well if the vikings were the one seed
i'd say kirk cousins if the vikings had
13 days to get ready yeah take on a team
that had to go to new orleans and win
and on a six-day turnaround travel
across the country to come play me i'd
say kirk cousins but it's jimmy
garoppolo no playoff experience as a
player he's been part of that patriots
cabal so he knows how the preparation
goes but he hasn't had to actually play
right the pressure is on him the
pressure is on the san francisco offense
and i firmly believe what the vikings
will do is try to take away the running
game neutralize george kittle and force
jimmy garoppolo to throw the ball to the
outside and hope that he makes some
mistakes sure early middle or late and
remember it was that overtime loss to
the seahawks where we saw garoppolo fire
on that last drive the 49ers had that's
right allowed russell wilson enough time
on the clock to get down and win the
game he's got to go wire to wire great
he cannot have that moment where the
game gets too big for him and yes he had
games this season that felt like playoff
games but
none of those games
if you lose means you go home you lose
this one and you're done you're right
you're the only show on tv this week
everybody's watching so as much as he
yes he performed great on sunday night
football and some other big moments
this is a whole you know different set
of circumstances and you're right
there's a ton of pressure on him you
good there
there is a ton of pressure on him though
i can't disagree with that you know they
brought him there he's delivered this
year he was a big question mark he's
answered a lot of those questions but
like man if he does throw an
interception in the first or second
quarter like how does he rebound from
that i don't know that'll be perfectly
remember i mean look and he's done
extremely well this season right there
was that that moment in training camp
where he had five straight throws yeah
there were interceptions right in
practice and then he had that goofy
quote that he likes throwing
interceptions in preseason games
universal reaction that was what the
hell are you talking about so we we the
jury was out on jimmy garoppolo going
into the season for health reasons and
for just overall is he good enough to
carry this load right and a lot of what
he's done
it's your buddy kyle shanahan drawing up
great plays there have been moments
where garoppolo makes it happen the
saints game he had some throws that were
him yep not kyle but but he's never
experienced anything like this before
this is not joe montana this is not
steve young
this is
jeff garcia maybe right
we'll see he's working
if he can be more than jeff garcia
that's basically well yeah he's working
to try to be joe montana or steve young
for the 49ers that's what he's working
to do so you're i mean listen he's
definitely under pressure i'm not going
to disagree with you there i think my
pick i'm going to go with andy reid i
think andy reid you know just the way
the season unfolded first off you just
talked about it there's 20 27 postga
post season games he's coached in he
hasn't won a super bowl yet he got a bye
week this year it's the texans they
already lost to them so there's the
pressure of that plus the pressure of oh
andy you're amazing on bye weeks well
you continue to be amazing for the
playoffs hey guess what andy the new
england patriots aren't there to be a
thorn in your side this year everything
is there
for kansas city to make a run and go to
the super bowl this year and maybe win
it depending on who they play we'll see
but i think there's a lot of pressure on
andy reid going into this matchup having
played a team that they've lost to and
now we're all going oh you're the two
seed you're at home we expect you to win
and deliver and i think that that puts a
lot on his shoulders and i think that's
a great choice that was high on my list
i am going to take now a guy that maybe
you wouldn't have taken maybe you would
have but
oh aaron rodgers there's some brushes
you're 36 years old you can't blame it
on mike mccarthy if you lose i mean
really this is it he's got his
opportunity to show that without mike
mccarthy i mean it's amazing we haven't
had that conversation all year yeah
we're obsessed with tom brady what he
could do without bill belichick bill
belichick what he could do without tom
brady we're going to find out what aaron
rodgers can do without mike mccarthy and
the knock on mccarthy was
only one super bowl appearance during
all those years with aaron rodgers and
it was fading deeper and deeper into the
rear view mirror now this is aaron
rodgers chance at home table is set
frozen tundra if you fall flat on your
face against the seahawks and you're
going to be 37 next year
are you going to get that second super
bowl maybe you won't no i i mean you're
you only get so many chances we've heard
him say earlier in the week and one of
the clips we showed here where he talked
to you know he talks about he thinks
about the super bowl every day uh and
yes yeah i mean you're right you know
when you win that second one that'll put
you into a different stratosphere i
think there's a lot of people too that
you know are haters on aaron rodgers and
they think that he needs that other
super bowl victory to be in the class
that i put him in and things like that i
don't think that i don't either but i
think there's a lot of people out there
i just want to make sure you're not
talking about me no no i don't i don't i
think many are saying well many are
saying because what you just said it we
hear people say all the time like oh it
may be really a shame if aaron rodgers
can only get to one super bowl in his
career because they're saying like damn
he's so talented how could they only get
to one and there is a lot of pressure on
hey and listen i'll be i'll be yeah
during those years where they were under
achieving and people were blaming
mccarthy i've raised the question before
at what point do we say that that aaron
rodgers may be part of the problem right
you got to make the throws sure you got
to deliver you got to get the wins in
those single elimination settings to try
to get to that second yeah no you're
right you're and it's going to be on him
i would be shocked if seattle lets the
green bay's offense run roughshod all
over them and run the ball with aaron
jones and you know what to the extent
that we still talk about the seahawks
maybe living with the demons of super
bowl 49 yeah we have to at least
consider that when aaron rodgers sees
that seahawk helmet he thinks back to
the nfc championship game where they had
the thing won i watched that game last
night on the plane flight over here
because it was on the nfl network i've
never seen a team obliterate another
team in the first half and then you
looked up and they were only up by like
16 points or something like that they
should have been up in that game 30 to
nothing and it shouldn't even been a
game and they let seattle hang around
but you're right that is a big thing all
right i'm going with kevin stefanski i
am you know kevin skovansky is trying to
get the cleveland browns head coaching
job we know he was one of the finalists
last year last week had a really good
showing against the new orleans saints
and they're off you know their offense
the vikings offense did some good things
made some big plays the microscope's
going to be on them again this week if
he goes out there and lays an egg and
doesn't do well and cleveland hasn't
made a decision on who they want to hire
and if he's down in the final two or
three hey elena egg in this kind of game
could hurt your chances of being hired
that way the browns would do the vikings
a huge favor if they would just hire
josh mcdaniels today you're right you
can just take it off the plate and
there's a report from albert brewer of
sports illustrated that josh mcdaniel's
wife is accompanying him to the browns
interview today right so you know you
don't you're not thinking about it
you're not worrying about you're not
auditioning for that next job with some
crazy trick play you know it drove me
nuts last week early in the game against
the saints they're running the ball well
they're running the ball well and then
here comes this goofy trick play that
gets blown up and those outside sweeps
that he wouldn't get away from and one
thing i've noticed this year it kind of
reminds me of the way that mike zimmer
handled case keenum a couple of years
ago zimmer is reluctant to keep praise
on stefanski he heaps it on kubiak yeah
and uh yeah i wonder if he's a little
well i think he's trying to tell you
something i think he's pro well yeah
when i see those kind of things i think
he's kind of trying to tell us you know
read between the lines i'm talking about
kubiak not stefanski so uh yeah go ahead
pick up all right next one for me and i
know this contradicts what i said
earlier in the hour but so what lamar
jackson's under pressure here even
though last year's loss i don't think
has any relevance now and i don't think
it develops a narrative it's the same
idea as jimmy garoppolo one seed at home
extra time and three weeks between games
that mattered can lamar jackson come out
out of the gates and be the guy he's
been all year i think he will be just
because he's under pressure doesn't mean
i believe he won't deliver i think he
will deliver but i think he will be
under pressure and we will see a guy who
is the best quarterback right now in the
nfl handle pressure better than jimmy
garoppolo better than aaron rodgers
better than any of the other
quarterbacks this week who may be
feeling the heat well he certainly
doesn't you know another guy that just a
young quarterback that's unflappable
just nothing seems to ever phase him
he's got tremendous self belief and
leadership and all those things and he's
changed there are no big moments no
almost big moments yeah you're right
they're all big moments and he said it
from the get-go he's there to win super
bowls that's what he's got his eyes on
and he's uh he's going for it all right
i'm gonna go a little off the radar here
all right because like okay yeah we know
some coaches quarterbacks under pressure
i'm going with the green bay field crew
okay because i've had an issue with them
all year long in green bay their field
has been crap a number of games this
year people have slipped and slid all
over the freaking field and i would say
about three or four home games this year
to where i know you heard me talk about
it and complain about it i complained to
our producer matt casey allowed to go
man i just watched another green bay
game nobody could stay on their feet
receivers are falling dbs are falling it
took away from the game and some of the
big plays that happened hey
they're expecting bad weather weather
there saturday night i don't want to see
that crap they better find the right way
to find the right temperature with the
heaters underneath the field because i
don't want to watch one of the biggest
games of the year and watch russell
wilson turning the corner and slip and
fall on his face or marshawn lynch is
about to be gone for a touchdown and he
makes a cut and the the field comes out
from underneath them so there's been a
number of moments like that this year
that have been very frustrating to me
and i'm putting the pressure on you guys
in green bay the field crew i don't know
any of your names it's on you they all
know your name though they know now
here's the thing though it's not like
you gain an advantage from that no
you're putting your own players at risk
too no i know i there is no advantage
you're exactly right in fact i think in
a lot of the games it's hurt green bay
because it's been like oh roger's just
trying to throw to devante adams and
devonte adams comes out of a break and
he slips and falls and whatever else
yeah i just don't want to see it for my
own personal and all of us fans i don't
want to see a field where guys are
falling all over the place and not being
able to play up to their capabilities
all right quick break before that let's
recap today's draft to the people under
the most pressure this weekend i've got
jimmy garoppolo aaron rodgers lamar
jackson chris has andy reid kevin
stefanski and the entire packers field
crew so take that that's his pick not
much
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports